So I just got home from the Moth
performing at the Moth last night.
It was my wow, my a hundred and
sixty ninth performance at The Moth.
I think about 131 Story Slams and 39 Grand
Slams, and actually some main stage shows.
A whole bunch is the point.
And yet, despite all of
those performances, I learned
something important last night.
On the way to the moth, I put my
story together in the car, which
is not something you should really
do, but I will occasionally do.
I knew what my story was like I sort
of know what happened, and I knew
what my beginning and ending were, but
I didn't really have any structure.
I hadn't spoken it out loud.
I hadn't put words to it.
So I got in the car.
I've got a two hour drive to Boston,
and I've got two friends with me.
Both of them attend moths all
the time with me, and so they're,
they're good at giving me advice.
And so I sort of picked through the
story once and figured out what it
would be, and then I said it a couple
more times, uh, you know, honing
some of the moments, finding the
right sentences, all of those things.
And then I got to the moth and
uh, my name was chosen fourth.
So I told my story and I. During
intermission, another storyteller who
happened to be attending who knows me
and know who knows that sometimes I
will put a story together in the car
and then perform it on stage, which
again, is not the smartest thing to
do, but something I occasionally do.
This storyteller asked my
friend Kaya, so I wanna know.
Is the story that Matt told you in
the car on the way to the Moth, the
same story that he just told on the
stage and Kaia said, absolutely not.
And I was surprised by her answer,
but it only took me a second to
realize she was totally correct.
The story I told in the car was
completely different than what
I had done on stage in the car.
What I did was create a structure.
I figured out what the scenes
would be, I knew what the
goals of each scene would be.
I sort of developed some
transitions from scene to scene.
But that was about all I did in the car.
I, I gave it words the first time,
but the words that I gave it in
the car were actually not the
same words I performed on stage.
I found new jokes to tell along the way.
I dropped information that
I felt wasn't necessary.
I responded to the audience when
they seemed to like something.
I added a little bit to it, and
when they seem not to respond
to something, I pulled back.
Kaya was completely right.
The story on stage really
came to life in a way.
It had not come to life in the car.
But what I did and what I tell
people all the time is I gave it
structure in which I could work.
I don't memorize stories.
I remember them.
I remember what happened to me, and
I create the structure so that when
I'm on stage, I can be flexible and I
can adjust, and I can meet the needs
of the audience, and I can meet the
time limit and all of those things.
So structure.
It's everything.
It is.
It is really the framework in which we
operate as storytellers and performers.
We need to know what the goal of
each scene is, how we get from one to
the other, what's the chronological
structure that we've created.
But ultimately, once we have that
in place, we have the freedom.
To adjust and create and
respond in meaningful ways.
I won the slam that night.
It was my 61st moth story slam win of
about 131 story slams, and so I did well.
I did well with structure.
Not with memorization, not with the
careful choice of vocabulary, not
with sentence structure, but with
an understanding about what my story
was, a framework in which I could
operate, and then the freedom to
create, adjust, modify, be myself
so that I wasn't someone who was.
Reciting memorized words on stage,
but actually telling a story
from my heart and my mind with
a little bit of planning ahead.
It's not the way I would advise anyone
to go and perform in front of 500 people.
It is not the way that you
should ever think about doing it.
This is one of those do, as I say,
not as I do situations, but what you
should be thinking is structure first.
Once you understand the beginning and the
end, and the scenes and the transitions
and the goals of each one of those
scenes, once you have that in place, the
sentences that you apply become your own.
And when they really are your own and
not so pre-planned that they feel like
they're memorized and performed, that
is when storytelling becomes alive.
So.
Kaia was right.
The story I told in the car was very
different than the story I told on stage
and yet ultimately it was the same story.
So structure, structure
first, everything else.
Second.